[Music]
all right thank you guys stuff we're
coming to this session and I'm so glad
that Xavier was so the one that ran into
AV issues not me
so one of the things I learned from
giving talks is that there's a very
strong positive correlation between the
number of memes and pictures you put in
your slides and how happy the audience
is you know from the session reviews I
I've been seen so so so I'm going to
just put a bunch of pictures down here I
won't do too much talking but at the end
I'm gonna do some demos because you
duniya me some contents in a Tech Talk
so we're gonna be talking about ml flow
and it's an open source platform for
managing the Domitian learning lifecycle
you know whatever that means what we're
gonna find out a little bit and it's a
community driven project mostly led by
the folks at data bricks with our studio
providing the our interface so let's
talk a little bit about the motivation
for for a project like this one of the
things that that the data scientists
have trouble with sometimes is that you
don't remember every model that you
tried so so let's say you're building a
neuro net so you've got a few layers and
maybe a residual connection here and
there and you you stumble across some
hyper parameters that that's in
promising so you sort of you know go go
into that direction and then tweak some
some numbers and then you know maybe
like an hour later you realize that you
know this that the performance isn't
great so so you want to sort of roll
back to to the previous version but then
you were so you know excited about your
results you didn't bother and you know
put pushing any of your committee name
your vehicle so you don't remember what
hybrid parameters you used so you know
chuckle please chuckle I
so we're gonna talk about how ml flow
might you know help with that situation
by logging your metrics and your hybrid
parameters and another thing that
sometimes people have issue with is
replicating your results and you might
want to reproduce your teammates numbers
or you might just want to reproduce your
own numbers from yesterday or last week
or last quarter and sometimes you know
you'll put that the code will run and
then you'll get some maybe different
results may be due to you some you know
random initialization of ways from
whatnot but sometimes you just doesn't
work coming no missing libraries
mismatched architectures and not every
data science project ends with a
PowerPoint deck and a steering committee
meeting sometimes you actually have to
take the models to production and you
know this is hard to find a common
common ground depending on where you are
between the folks who prototype the
models and the folks who actually need
to take the models to production and and
this is exacerbated by the fact that
there are just so many different machine
learning libraries out there and there
are also different deployment targets
right so that there are different
libraries you can use to train the
models and then there are different ways
to sort of deploy these models so if you
got you know it's that the number of
ways you can sort of combine the the
prototyping and that deployment just
expands exponentially so if you are at
some specific companies mostly out there
in Silicon Valley you might say oh you
know we got this all solved but then
what about everyone else what do you do
so you're good you go online you're do
some Google searches you'll be like oh
what's everyone else doing and then
you'll find that especially for model
deployment is is that the
so many different things out there and
it's kind of tough so over the past a
couple years there's been a lot of
efforts in a machine learning community
and and also within the art community to
try to solve this problems or at least
attempt to solve these problems
and you know I only think that we we
won't ever come up with like one
framework that's just going to work for
everyone but I think we can try to
segment the problems such that you can
have a set of standard practices that
sort of will apply to - to most people
so back to the topic ml flow it's it's
got three different components
it's got tracking which is going to help
you keep track of your hyper parameters
some nose and some metrics from your
experiments the project component
bundles your project and environment so
others can reproduce your results and
the model component allows you to use
your lies in package or your models so
you can deploy them so of course you
know I did this dustin making any sense
so so we're gonna do some demos to show
what this thing actually looks like and
if i can figure out all right here we go
okay so let's let's try to do this so
back row can you give me a thumbs up if
you can see or not okay I think I'm good
so we we can you know load a library by
the what is it Songkran so you can just
install it off of plan and I'm just
gonna do something really really general
right now so we can say mlobach paren
and then let's say we want to block the
food program and then about your happens
to be 42 so what is this doing about
background is this basically longitude a
server
and starting an experiment and actually
logging you know this parameter so we
can come in here my feeling me take a
step back so so this is like the default
view of the of the MMO flow interface so
we can go into our experiment run here
and then we see that our parameter fuel
has a bit blocked so so the cool thing
is that this is not only for machine
learning if you have other experiments
that you want to keep track of you can
also use this mechanism so let's say now
we want to lock a metric we come back
here we see that we have that metric
that that's been recorded and you know
there are other things we can do there's
tags your notes you know you can write
whatever you want so that that's sort of
the tracking functionality and we can
now go to models so so have you did roll
a little extra boost model to you to try
to classify iris and then what we have
here is a model to start attributes of
that same problem just using terrorists
and tensorflow
so I'm going to run this real quick just
go through the code standardizing values
normalizing values and then here we can
oh my god forget to mention when we when
we log this parameter right here we
started an experiment run and then after
you're done with your ex your experiment
run you need to end the run and once we
do that you can see that you know
there's also at the race
associate with your experiment run so
that that dot you know might might be
helpful when you're trying to compare
different ways to try to turn the models
and you might you know spend ten hours
to just get a little bit of accuracy and
that's not worth it but we can also use
this context manager with the width
function and we can trend this very
simple a feed-forward neural net for a
few epochs and see what happens so you
know you can see real-time that the loss
is going down yeah and the matrix is the
accuracy is going up so we're doing
great and then we can go back to our UI
and we see that we have our neural net
training run that has also been logged
and because we added a callback in
Kara's model fit call we can see that ml
flow has also logged the the accuracy
for each epoch okay so one other thing
we did was we saved the art that took
the model as as an artifact so you can
basically save like anything you want
and associated with an experiment so
what we can do right now is we can
attempt to to serve this model locally
just using a web server so using this
function and most of all artifacts serve
and our model directory is the Charis
model because that's where we locked it
and then we can provide the run
identifier so we'll do that and then we
got we got a model that's being served
right now it's for 1890 and
I got us prepared so we can basically
post a bunch of predictor data to to
this predict endpoint and then see if we
get some results back so so we do so so
these are like the the probabilities of
of each class okay so let's go back we
can show a couple more things you can
also run projects from from github so
let's just do this real quick and I can
just show what's going down there so so
basically what it is it's doing is it's
pulling Cole from github and then
spinning up many environments to execute
this code and then it's going to lock
the results to two to a training run and
if we actually go to this URL and our
infant point was just render our file we
see that we're using a random forest
classifier now using spark to try to
classify the flowers so we see that the
run has succeeded so we can go back to
the avail flow interface and we see that
here we have the parameters that that
were passed to to the to the project run
and then also stopped metrics associated
with it and the cool thing about this is
that it records the exact the exact
commits which this code was to pull from
so you can actually you know click on
this to to navigate a repository at a
specific point in time yeah so I think
that's all I have to show you guys so
you know definitely think about what
sort of applications you can apply this
to
in your own endeavors so I think do we
have time for questions
yep we have some time for questions if
anybody has some
one of the things I was wondering about
do you have to use the ml flow interface
in order to retrieve the metrics which
are recorded or is it possible to export
it to you know a flat file or to some
kind of log yeah that there's a there's
an API that you can use that's currently
not exported yet in the in the our
package but that is our a wrapper on the
rest interface that you can use to
potentially do that so you don't have to
use the interface if you don't want to
and then you can also build your own
interface to suit your knees
any other questions hi Kevin thanks how
what is the state of collaboration
between Python and our so can I have an
experiment that has parts of its code
and Python the other part in our and
track them in the same experiment and
I'm all flow yes yes so here I
demonstrated for example this this call
to pull some code from github this did
not have to be Oracle it could have been
it could be in Python called and if we
actually go back to this did this run
right here you see that there's a run
command that's basically a command line
command that anyone can use to reproduce
your results so if your data son is
working are anyone else even if they
have never seen a single line of our
code they can you know try to put
different hyper parameters into your
model and get some results back so we
basically try to abstract a way that the
implementation of the model from the
people who want to use the models hi hi
I saw in some of the code that you were
making calls to the recipes package
maybe yes is that integrated into ml
flow in any way so the cool thing about
ml flow is that like in the beginning I
was just logging random stuff so if you
wanted to record specifics about your
trip your data pre-processing step you
can you can definitely do that so that
there's really no limit on like what you
can sort of put in there so so we know
we log an entire Chara's model in there
too so you can put like pictures and you
know audio file if you if you want
you
[Music]